All right, welcome everyone to DTPs seminar
today, before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have questions, you
cannot mute and ask questions
during the talk. But otherwise, if you want to be
don't, you don't. If you don't want
to interrupt the presentations,
you can use chat room and post your
questions so that we can address them
in Q and A session at the end. Second, today's
DDPS seminar is open to external audience,
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed. So please watch out. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel. That's about it. Let
me introduce our speaker today. It is an honor to
host Dr Kyung Min Yao, who is a research scientist
at IBM TJ Watson Research Center. He received a
PhD in applied math from Brown University in 2011
before joining IBM and research in 2013
he was a postdoctoral fellow at the Lawrence
Berkeley National Lab. Dr Yao has been working
on a range of research areas from soft matter
physics to atmospheric sciences. Since joining
IBM Research, his research interest has
been focused on hybrid physics, statistics,
models and deep learning for random dynamical
systems. Today, Dr Yao will talk about reducing
data resolution for better reconstruction, super
resolution of Navier stokes flow. I'm sure we are
going to hear a wonderful talk. Now, let me before
we before I pass the button to the doctor. Yeah,
let me ask a in somewhat informal
questions to get to know him better.
So
I know you like to travel with family,
and I happens to know that your wife
is, you know, some artists, yeah, job,
if you can share your the most favorite, the place
you have been so far and and, Hello, yeah. So it's
more like a so my spare time is mostly devoted to
helping out my wife, and she's actually painter.
Bucha also does a photography and so on. So we
kind of most impressed, most interesting places.
We traveled to our Iceland. So we went to Iceland
like three times or in the winter, so that you
don't really got interrupted by any other people.
So it was quite fascinating. If you go Iceland in
winter, always be prepared, because, you know,
sometimes this can happen one time, the first
time we went to Iceland, then we actually got
stuck in a mountain and stayed night in the car,
and the next day we walked down the mountain to
get rescued. So it was very fascinating place to
us. Was it because of the snowstorm? Yeah, because
of snow, I rented a small car which couldn't move,
so I tried to shovel it out, but it didn't
work. So yeah, next day we walked like three,
four hours to find a farm and get rescued. So oh
my goodness, that sounds devastating. Devastating.
It was interesting. It was interesting. Okay,
well, thank you for sharing though. Okay, well,
thank you for sharing interesting story. Okay,
the floor is yours. Okay, great. Thank you,
Dr Cha for the introduction and the invitation.
So I'm Kyung Min from IBM Research. The topic
I'm going to talk today is mostly about
like good old fashioned state estimation
problem. But here the interest is that when we
use super resolutions, sometimes we can get a
better reconstruction of the ground truth state,
particularly when the data is noisy. So this is
the joint study with my collaborators,
Maggie Mike and Segi. So in this study,
we almost all contributed equally. Maggie mostly
did the numerical simulations, and Mike and Segi
were responsible for the theoretical derivations.
I just did a little bit of everything. So so this
is actually motivation of the study. When you have
some observation of physical phenomena. It's very
difficult to get away from corruption. This is
one example how they actually measure the fluid
velocity. The device shown on top left is called
Particle Tracking velocimetry. We call it PTV. So.
So in this PTB, they have suspensions
of neutrally buoyant particles,
and the movement of this neutral rebound
particle is captured by high speed camera,
so that you eventually end up
with some images, something like
bottom left. And then if you can
identify the positions of the particle,
comparing both images, then you can find, you
can approximate the velocity at some locations.
And you can imagine, if we
use this kind of device,
then the measurement we are getting out
of this PTV is highly noisy, so the high
resolution measurement we can get into something
look like top left corner on the right figure.
Although we can have some small scale
structures, the data is highly corrupted,
so it's very difficult to understand what's really
going on. And then later, if we change the, say,
some parameters such as the length of average
or green space, or length of correlations,
then you can move from the top left to the bottom
right. So at this stage, now we have the much
smooth velocity field. But the problem is that
now all the high, small scale structures went
away. So now the question we have is that, how can
we what kind of resolution we want to work with,
and how can we deal with the noise? So one of the
interesting thing, one of the interesting, one of
the interest is that if we can start from this
bottom right corner that you've barely smoothed
out low resolution information. And if we can use
this information to reconstruct this high scale,
a very high wave number phenomena, then
that's going to be the ideal scenario,
and that's where the super resolution
comes in. So super resolution is this
is not like a new area. Super resolution
has been studied for a few decades. Now,
the classical super resolution problem is actually
using a sequence of low resolution images to
reconstruct the high resolution data. So when you
have some observation function which is fixed,
the observation function in this case is
denoted by this matrix, M, for example.
Then this high resolution the ground truth
data is projected on this low resolution
image by observation function. And then, as
we combine different frames of moving object,
then different areas are captured by this, this
observation function, then the basic idea is that
we can stitch these different information
together to generate the high resolution,
high resolution image. So in this example, they
actually shows that if we combine these many,
like 55 low resolution frames, then they could
come up with this high resolution, high resolution
reconstruction of ground truth.
But we with the development of deep learning now,
the idea of super resolution has been changes
that, instead of solving optimization problems
to reconstruct the high resolution information
by using a low resolution sequence of low
resolutions. Now the idea is that we do every of
these reconstruction in the training time. So once
we have a tremendous amount of training data, then
we do we can actually find a structure from this
low resolution image to generate high resolution
reconstruction, so that instead of having multiple
images, now in deep learning time, we are mostly
looking at a single image super resolution, that
we just give this information. And we want to zoom
in to we want to zoom into these rectangles and
get a high resolution image. So this results show
these super resolutions for this super resolution
for this particular area, and this Bicubic is just
like a simple bicu interpolation, which is mostly
similar to the low resolution data we have. But
when you apply this deep learning method, as shown
here, the deep learning method provides much more
realistic images than the and simple by keeping
interpolations. So thanks to the success of deep
learning in this single image, super resolutions
now it has been applied to many different physical
problems in first example shown here. Now they
are. They went to really extreme. The super
resolution problems that people usually looked
at is mostly like four times or eight times.
Super resolution. But in this particular
study, they looked at a 50 times super
resolution problem that they started to
start from very low resolution image,
and then they obscured it to the medium they
have two models. One is that of scaling from
low resolution to medium resolution, and they
have another model stage of scaling from medium
resolution to high resolutions. So that they
claimed that if we have this step wide approaches,
they could achieve 50 times super
resolutions. And model was applied
to some global scale climate problems. In
this case, they the what's shown on the
left is the original low resolution image,
and using the method they can generate,
they can generate the super resolution data shown
on the right, which looks much more realistic,
but more quantitative. Study is shown on
the right. In this case, in this study,
they are looking at the top round
channel flows. So here it's mostly
like a four time super resolution problem.
The right most column shows the DN Omega
simulation. That's the ground truth. And
when they supply the low resolution data,
which is shown on the left, then their neural
network can generate the higher resolution data,
which looks much more realistic. And what's very
what's interesting in this study is that when you
look at the energy spectrum of the super
resolution research that is shown on here
in this
energy spectrum, the black line is ground truth,
and the vertical line shown here is the cut off
length, meaning that they generate the low
resolution data by using spectral filter,
which cuts off All the old high wave number of
information after the reconstruction, the energy
spectrum of the reconstructed field is shown as
symbols which is almost identical to the ground
truth. So it means that this is super resolution
method can actually recover the ground truth,
which is very generating the images that is very
close to the physical phenomena that's happening.
But what we actually need to
remember here is that even though there
was success in Super, you know, applying
super resolutions for the physical problems, the
super resolution is a reported problem, so that
you don't really have a unique solutions to match
the low resolution data. So there can be infinite
number of solutions to match the low resolution
data from high resolutions. One example shown here
is that on the left we can have apparently broad
image of Obama. But after the reconstruction, they
get someone else. And what is shown here is that
they have the very broad image of some person,
and they their neural network is generating
many different possibilities, and all of these
possibilities apparently different people can
match the low resolution data. So in a sense,
super resolution is important problem. There is
no unique solution. So one possibility is that if
we have the recall super resolution reconstruction
of a single image to image, then the reconstructed
field may satisfy the kinematic conditions. For
example, if we have incompressible flows, then it
may satisfy the mass conservation. But there is no
guarantee that this satisfies the net, satisfy the
reconstruct field satisfies this a dynamic
constraint, such as moment conservation.
So there are new studies that comes out.
They in this individual studies, the people
are started looking at the sequence to sequence
reconstruction. So now we are going back to the
classical time of day. We try to reconstruct.
We try to do the super resolution based on
the sequential information and in to actually
satisfies the dynamic constraint. So in this plot,
the top, in this study, what they did is
that they are looking at the sequence of
low resolution images centered around the
high resolution reconstruction they want
to have. And then in this plot, the
figure on the right is ground truth,
and one left is the multiple, multiple time
step snapshot reconstruction, and the left
is single natural reconstruction.
So it looks almost the same, but.
The multiple snapshot is a little bit better.
So when you get the statistical properties
that is shown here, again, this is the energy
spectrum of turbulent flows. The black line
is ground truth. And here, this blue line
is the multiple snapshot reconstruction,
and this red line is a single snapshot
reconstruction. So they actually showed
that having multiple snapshots to the
reconstruction super resolution has a
better accuracy than single snapshot, one single
snapshot to snapshot of super resolutions.
And this is the study that just came out in
this society, they also have the similar idea.
Instead of minimizing the error between low
resolution and high resolution in each snapshot,
now they are proposing to have a time marching
error to satisfy the dynamic constraint and in
fear on the right in this figure, the left
first column is ground truth. Second column
is the low resolution data. They essentially
take the scales and and the compute the and get
the average inside of scale. And right columns
are super resolution reconstructions using this
dynamic loss. And you can see that they are very
close with okay. Do you have Kirsten, Yes, Doctor,
can you talk about conservation properties like
mass, momentum and energy in this super resolution
because they are important for
incompressible flows? Yeah,
that's actually very good, Kirsten, so
in this case,
that's actually one of the purpose why we
want to, why this author was going into this,
this kind of time matching loss to the time
matching rules, essentially having compelling the
moment momentum conservations between the ground
juice data and the super in the super resolution
models to satisfy, so that each likely to satisfy
the momentum conservation. But in always that
the this is this provides a soft constraint, not
harder constraint. So always, the issues with this
deep learning model is that it's very hard to
make the model to satisfy the hard constraint.
So we it may approximately satisfy the moment
conservation, but not exactly also same story
goes to the mass conservation. So usually you
need to have the actual mass conservation in
in the in rows function. Otherwise
it's going to be very tricky to
trick it to 35 Okay, so with a
different another question here,
yeah, it says the Sean is asking, what is the
definition for the N theta and variable fee?
Oh, this fee is a time marching operator,
and U is ground truth value.
And then here what it is that it is first
to C is a projection to the low resolution
data. And then n we and then we apply N for the
reconstruction, then applying it to the time,
much more parameter. So we first to have
the ground truth to the low resolutions,
and then neural network to reconstruct
high resolutions. And then applying time,
much more parameter, and comparing these two.
So the anyway, the method here is that if you
look at this error plot. So this figure, the
vertical line is the l2 error. Horizontal line
is some computation parameters. And this green
line is a single snapshot super resolutions.
And this red line, this blue line, is multi
snapshot of super resolutions, and it shows the
multi snap super resolutions has a smaller errors
than the single snap charge. So it has better
it has a better approximation of ground truth.
And what's interesting in this study is that
they compare the flow field predictions using the
data or simulations, and the super resolutions,
data simulation, in this case, may
use Newtonian logic. And what they
found is that when there is a
noise in the initial conditions,
then in Super resolutions, the noise
in Super later, super resolution method, the
noise effect of the noise doesn't propagate a lot,
you know, in downstream, so that the noise is
quickly removed while they are you they when they
use data or simulations, the noise propagates
much longer, meaning that super resolution or.
Also has some denouement capability.
So the
so this also did study essentially
say that in Super resolutions,
we want to have some dynamic we want to improve
some dynamic effect. And that's actually what
we are interested in in in this study. So
if we simply, if we simplify the system,
now we can have, we can simplify the system
in this way that we have the original system,
that that has the equation, that has the
time machine system of a high resolution
information denoted by mu, H, and we, and we,
when we and then from this original system,
now we get the high resolution information that
is filtered to generate the low resolution data.
And then we have another system that is
called observer this observer system is
supposed to have the high same occasion with
the high resolution system. But this observer,
this observer system, doesn't really
have the same initial conditions as
well as it. It doesn't really have the direct
information over this high resolution ground
truth. We only have an observation of this low
resolution information. Then the and DC, this
very simple schematic, explains that is
captured the essence of this dynamic,
super resolution problem we are looking at. Then
the next question we can naturally have is that
when we have very complex nonlinear dynamical
system that is used that can be chaotic,
such as neighbors applications, then for
chaotic systems, what we know is that even
small perturbations eventually make the make two
systems diverge. But in this observer system,
we don't, we don't see the ground truth
of this high resolution information.
We only see the filtered low resolution
information. Then the question is that,
when the system is chaotic, whether this
is a super resolution model can really
approximate the ground truth or not,
and
in TRA and the answer to this question is
comes from very interesting phenomena called
Chaos synchronization. So chaos synchronization
means that when you have two chaotic systems,
sometimes by exchanging informations,
these two chaos systems can synchronize
with each other. So this is one of the
early examples of chaos synchronization,
that on the left hand we have the
original Ross equations, RO system,
and on the right hand we have another Ross
system that is starting from different initial
conditions. But what they found is that if
we share, if we have one of the dimensions
of this original system to drive this observer,
this observer system, then eventually we can,
we can get this observer system synchronized
with the original system. So that this kind
of synchronized synchronization of character
system has been studied, studies extensively,
and there is a very nice review of this corporate
dynamic system in this in this paper. So this
kind of Kirsten synchronization was actually
observed in turbulent flows. So in this study,
they what they in this, this is very interesting
study where they have this navy soxification,
and they use some kind of spectra filter to
generate the low resolution data denoted by u1
and then now they have the observer system. This
observer system only using this low resolution
data and moving in time. What they found
is that this delta t is the deviation of
this this this observer system from the ground
truth, and then what they found is that this,
this, this deviation is actually diminishing
to the motion accuracy. And the rate of this
decay of the deviation is exponentially fast,
so that they actually found when, when the
when, when the low resolution data covers
up to 10 or 15 times comor of time scale,
then you can the this low resolution,
this is super resolution, six.
Can actually recover the ground truth
almost exactly. So here the left one
is the input data. That's the low resolution
data, and the right column is the is the super
resolution reconstruction that that really
preserve a very small scale characteristics,
and it actually converges the
original high resolution system.
So the same study has been there also has been
same study on the chaos synchronization in
neighbor sub flows. And what they suggested
is that this chaos synchronization in neighbors
applications actually occurs over a wide range
of a parameters. And then they they suggested
that this chaos synchronization is actually a
properties of networkation, not the spec,
not related to specific data or simulation
algorithms. So this type of convergence
of observer system to super resolution,
observer system to to to ground truth has
been studied a lot in data or simulation
community. So this is one of the old study
that was done by orphan TT. This is very
classic study that should mathematically
show proof that in 2d tolerance, that this
this super resolution also so data or
simulation actually converges to the ground
truth. In more recent studies, they actually
mathematically proved, also intuitive flows
that when you use a super when you have super
resolution models, under certain conditions
that this is super resolution, the error of this
super resolution model decreases exponentially
fast and converges to the ground truth system
with the motion accuracy. So what essentially
says is that when we have a very clean system
that is noise, that doesn't contain any noise,
then super resolution model have the potential
to actually reconstruct the ground truth,
in particular for the Navy assort fluid. Then
let's go back to the motivation in the beginning
that we start now. We are looking at the system
that is not noise free. We are interested in
reconstruction of noise observations. Then we have
many different behaviors. We have depending on the
filter we are using, we can have many different
resolutions. Now we want to have some guideline,
watch the resolution we want to work with, and if
we want to, if we use some of these resolutions,
whether we have a guarantee of some kind
of convergence to the ground truth system,
so that, so far, there are many studies of super
resolutions in for dynamic, turbulent flows and
many physical systems. Most of this, most of
the studies have been, have been empirical,
and what we wanted to do achieve in this study
is to provide some theoretical guideline whether
this is super resolution model is actually working
well if it works under what kind of conditions.
So let me now talk about the problem setup of our
study here we are still looking at two dimension,
two dimensional, turbulent flows. The original
system we are we are interested is that we
are using is something called chrome work
flow. This is essentially two dimensional
incompressible Navier solicitation. And here
the driving force is given by some signs,
some sinusoidal function, some sine function.
And then the computational domain is periodic.
So we have two pi in two pi in both directions,
and we use a pseudo spectra solver with 512,
mode in each directions. So in the initial
conditions, we randomly generate the initial
conditions by by seeding a very high wave
number of vertices. And then as time goes,
we the vortices evolved to generate the turbulent
field, as shown here. This plot is starting. This
plot is a time evolution of the vorticity field,
starting from time equal to zero to 13. So
now we have the observer system.
The Observer system is same as,
the same as the ground truth system, so each
it has, it's still neighbors application to
the but this observer system has a different
initial condition than the ground truth system,
because we don't, we don't know the initial
conditions, and this observer system is.
Output to the ground truth by this feedback
mechanism. Here l is some parameter that related
to the relaxation time scale of this observer
system to the ground truth. And this C is a rule.
This is a role, resolution, projection operator,
and this C is defined as in this equation.
Essentially, what this operator does is we compute
average velocity in sub domain denoted by omega j,
and then we distribute this average over the
over this subdomain. So if you look at the figure
on the right, then this is the total computational
domain. Then we divide this total computational
domain into a disjoint subdomains, and in each
subdomain we compute the average velocity,
and then they distribute this average,
average velocity within this sub domain.
So we have a piecewise continuous velocity
field in in in the in the whole domain.
And this observer system is solved by a second
order finite, different finite element method,
so so that it has lower order accuracy than
the one used for the data generation process
and and this priority should satisfy some of
the regularity conditions that is shown here.
But I will get back to this
conditions later in the talk.
And we generate the noise observation,
the noise observation, is generated by
adding a adding white noise to the
ground truth. So this is a small y,
so this you is a high resolution ground truth.
And then we add a random noise, white noise
to this ground truth, to have noise observations.
And then we apply this low resolution operator
C to the high resolution noise observation to
generate the data that we are supplying to the
observer. So this Y denotes the data, and this
figure shows the process that the left figure
is the ground truth velocity. And then when
we add the noise, the corrupted data looks
like the figure on the mirror. And then the
role resolution projection of this corrupted
data that is we are supplying to the super
resolution model is shown on the right. So,
so So this low resolution data is, of
course, much less, no easy than the
than this high resolution data, but it is
also very different from the ground truth,
because we are filtering out many of the
important, many of the small scale information.
So in this, in this, in this corruption process,
we don't actually request this noise, noise eta to
be Gaussian, but we assume that this noise, this
noise has a finite variance. So that we apply,
we introduce a regularity conditions.
This regularity condition means that
this integral inside the bracket is
essentially a variance of the noise,
and this variance of the noise multiplied
by some constant is less than one,
meaning that so we we assume that there are
some positive coefficient r which can be used
to bound the variance, so as long as the noise
is bounded, then this condition is satisfied.
Now the main results,
main research of the of our study, is
summarized here, but here I'm not going to
explain details about these theorems, but
essentially, what we try to show in this
theorem is that when we have this observer system
which is coupled to the ground truth by using the
low resolution observation, then this observer
system converges exponentially fast to the
neighborhood of the ground truth. And when there
is when there is no noise in the observation,
what is found before was that this G will
exactly converge to you. But when there is noise,
then then this observer system converges to
you, but each only stage in the neighborhood
not exactly converging to the ground truth, so
that we have the convergence zone where this
perturbation part of the velocity field
converges to the original ground truth.
Us. And once, once this
observer is inside of this error bound,
then each going, each going to stay there
without, without escaping, so that this
convergence zone is global, attracting.
So this is so here, this
is the main research of the
study. And let me just briefly
sketch what this theorem actually
derived and what what actually what it actually
means. So we first start from the weak form
of the nabius application. That here the first
line the weak form of the ground truth system,
and the bottom is the observer system. And
we subtracted these two to get the evolution
equation of the error. So here, in this equation,
what denoted by E, is the is the error, error term
that the ground truth velocity field are subjected
by the observer velocity field. And then the
idea of this proof is that if we can
find the bound of each of these terms,
then we can have we can understand how this
evolutionification will behave so but I'm not
going to explain details about all of the other
terms does. But what we are interested in here is
what happens with something happening in this
term. In this term, F is the driving force of
the nebucha that's known, and this is capital F,
is each the feedback force, so that this capital
F is essentially a combination of the driving
force with this observer, low resolution input.
And then if we manipulate this capital app driving
force term, now we can decompose it into two
terms. One is that we have the projection
of the error, and another term is the low
resolution projection of the noise, and so that if
we look at this term now, we can actually compute
the upper bound of this inner product, as shown
here. And what we are again in this upper bound,
what we are interested in is only what's happening
with this inner product between between the noise
and the error term. So here, this is actually
typo. It should be eta, not psi. But anyway,
what we're interested in is only this in inner
product between noise and the error term and then
the bound of this noise. This noise in a product
is shown here. So they refer to just write out,
write down the definition of the inner product,
and then we use the regularity condition that we
introduced it before to come to get the bound,
to get the bound of the of this inner product
and at the end, at the end of the day,
after doing some manipulations, now, we can
find the upper bound of this inner product
in terms of the l2 error and the
coefficient sigma is defined in
here. The Sigma depends on the size of the
sub domain. This H is a side of sub domain,
and r is the parameter that depends
on the variance of the knowledge.
So
after doing, again, after doing, after doing
some manipulation, this is again, writing down
this inner product, and we we looked at what have
what's happening inside of this inner product,
between knowledge and error. Then we end up
with some we end up with some conditions that
we can find, some corruption to Delta features
between zero and one. And once you have the
conditions that this delta multiplied by
L to error is larger than the the sigma,
sigma coefficient from the regularity conditions,
then what we can? We can? We can further reduce
the the temporal time evolution of error into
this form. And then if we have further conditions
that the that the first term is less than the
second term, then we can even simplify the error.
Evolution equation shown here. So what it
essentially says is that the upper bound of
the time evolution over l2 error, l to error means
that the super resolution reconstruction and the
ground truth is bounded is exponentially decaying
function. So we have the relaxation process that
the upper bound of l2 error is decaying, and then
to up to get this term. We actually made some
of the assumptions that this l2 error is bigger
than this coefficient sigma. So in other words,
when this add to error is bigger, bigger than
this, bigger than the right hand side, then
error is decaying exponentially fast. And when
add to error is less than the right hand side,
then we don't know, we don't know whether
it's going to decrease or increase but,
but that's not our interest at this
time. So based on these conditions,
now we can have the zone of
convergence, meaning that
when add to error, is bigger than
this joinable convergence, denoted by,
denoted by here, then it's already exponentially,
exponentially fastly decreasing, so that this
joint of convergence essentially provides us
the upper bound of l2 error. Now let's look at
this upper bound a little bit more closely, so
that this is the definition of the joint error,
the conversion stone, then from the regular from
the regularity conditions we had before. Again,
what the what's happening inside
of this bracket? It is just the
variance averaged over the domain. And
let's say we have the computational grid,
or data grid that is shown here, that is
high resolution data with grid size delta x,
and we have a subdomain that is shown in this red
rectangles that have size h. Then we can define a
compression ratio that's the ratio between the
size of the subdomain and the grid space. Then,
using this compression ratio, now, we can show
that whatever that the every expectation of this
integration inside the bracket can
be written as sigma square. That's
the variance of the noise divided by
c square. That's the compared to this
compression ratio. Larger C means
that we have a coarse resolutions.
So using these conditions at the using
these conditions at the end of the day,
we can bound all of the expressions, and we find
that the zone of convergence can be expressed by
this equation, so that here this omega is the
size of the computational domain, and data is
some parameter positive parameter we can choose.
Then what this equation essentially says is that
the upper bound of error is proportional to the
variance, standard deviation of the noise. But
what's interesting is that it's actually inversely
proportional to the grid size, so as long so if we
each very counter intuitive, because when you
have the high larger information, the usual
intuition is that we want to somehow work with
this high resolution information to get a better
reconstruction. But what this research actually
says is that if we reduce the resolution of the
of this super resolution system, then
we can resolution over the input data to
super resolution, we can actually have a better
reconstruction so that this, this Coronavirus,
actually summarizes all of the derivations all
over the profile just outlined that this figure,
the quantity on the left, defines over the
joinable convergence, and this general conversion,
that the upper bound of error is essentially
decreased when you when the data resolution
gets closer so that, so here, that's the
theoretical results. Now we are trying to
show the not now we are trying to see that if the
theoretical results can be observed in the actual
numerical experiment. So here we do so. So this is
our line of the numerical experiment. The original
system, the two dimensional negotiation, was
solved by the pseudo spectral method. And we are.
Using 512 flier mode for to solve this
neighbor substitution. And the observer
system is now solved by second order
finite element method. And then again,
shown on the right is the high resolution grid.
And we have this sub domain denoted by this
red curve,
and then we this. The size of this
domain is denoted by h, and we have
compression ratio that's giving us
the this giving us the ratio of super
resolution and the noise magnitude here
is that the variance of noise is proportional
to the turbulent kinetic energy. Turbulent
kinetic energy is defined, defined on here,
and then we use it different we looked at the
different primary range that the viscosity
change from zero to one, five to 009,
and then different noisy letters
and different compression ratios.
And the actual code is, is, you
can find the actual code in this,
in this GitHub report, the this is open source
code. You can, you can download and test it.
So this is
the research of the bellow theory construction
for the parameter range shown here. So then now we
are looking at the compression ratio of 32 meaning
that we are looking at 32 times super resolutions.
So this is the ground truth state in the initial
conditional ground truth state, and we superposed
noise to the initial state. And then this is the
low resolution input data that is averaged by 3232
by 32 grid. And then the right figure showing here
is a super resolution reconstruction, but initial
condition is of Super Regional reconstruction
is just like almost zero in this case.
And then after some time, here we are looking at t
equal to eight. Then we then figure on the left is
ground truth, and we have the corrupted data. And
then eventually the reconstruction shown on the
right is very close to the ground truth. And the
figure on the figure on the middle is the actual,
actual role resolution data that was supplied to
the super resolution models. So that, if you look
at the figure on the bottom, then the left, this
is the velocity field in the center of the domain.
This is the
horizontal velocity at the center of domain.
And you can see that this is a ground truth and
this is the low resolution data, and super
resolution reconstruction, in this case,
becomes very close to ground truth, even though
low resolution data doesn't really have this
high small scale structures. So this figure,
it shows the reconstruction error at one time
snap. This is a snapshot. It's the same snapshot
at t equal to eight. And here we are looking at
the error field at different compression ratio.
Compression ratio one means that each like a data
or simulation algorithm, and then we apply the
super resolutions. Then, as you can see here, that
as we increase the compression ratio, then the
error gets smaller and smaller. And in this case,
if you get the color bar, the color bar changes
from point one to minus one, while the color bar,
color bar of the ground truth changes from two
to minus two, so that the error range here is
much smaller than the actual velocity field.
And this is consistent with the study that I
explained in the beginning that when you had where
they found that the super resolution models have
very strong characteristics in the denoising
cap, very strong, very strong denoising
capability. And we also showed that when you
use super resolution, the error becomes much
less than as we increase the size of the
as we increase the size of the sub domains.
And now we are looking at the convergence of
this super resolution, the relative error.
In this case, it is defined by l2 error divided
by the velocity fluctuations. And the reason is
that based on the joint definition of the general
convergence and the definition of this variance of
the noise. Now what you can see is that this
is a relative error. Should should scare as
the conversion stone like it should
decay at the compression ratio. So
if you look at this case, so you both of
them are from same knowledge level, 1.6
Is at different viscosity. What you can see is
that, as we so this line is the c equal to one,
meaning that there is no compression.
And as we increase the compression ratio,
the super resolution ratio, then we see that the
relative error actually decreases. And then in the
beginning, we also starting from different
we are starting from zero velocity field,
so we have different initial velocity than the
ground truth. And this the the deviation from the
ground truth decays exponentially fast. So that
is consistent with the geo record predictions. One
other thing we observe is that as we increase the
size of sub domain, the super resolution ratio,
and it first decrease, but then eventually,
when we when we decrease the super when you
increase super resolution ratio further than the
error starting to diverge, the system starting
to diverge from the ground truth. So the each
first decreasing and each going up to here.
That's because in theoretical predictions, we have
some necessary conditions for the convergence,
that the size of the subdomain, the ratio of
the super resolution should be bounded by some
constant multiplied by the viscosity, which is
inversely proportional to the Reynolds number.
Now, for the interest of time, I'm going
to skip this figure and just go going to
explain about this last figure. So in
this last figure. Now this is actually
summarization of all the experiments here
we are looking at three different viscosity
and the vertical axis is the relative error.
Horizontal axis is the super resolution ratio,
and different color means the different
uh. Noise, noise level, so that
going from top to bottom, we have, we have
noise from change, noise level change from 1.6
to zero, so that the line on the bottom is
actually noise free, super resolution case.
So what the fourth thing we notice is that if
you look at if you see the figures, the the line
here is C to the minus point five. So we actually
see that when we increase the compression ratio,
the error is a decrease error, error decreases,
but the but the ratio that error decreases is
actually much slower than the theoretical
predictions. In theoretical predictions,
we predicted C to the minus one, but in numerical
experiment, we have c to the minus point five.
But one reason that we have
slower convergence is because of
the you, because we are using a low,
low order of CFP solver for the observers. The
ground truth was generated by spectral method,
while the low observer was solved by
second order finite element method.
The reason we use a low order, low order
safety solver for the observer is that
we want to mimic the real life scenario where we
don't really have that kind of high resolution
info. We don't really have that kind of high
fidelity models to reconstruct the velocity
field. So if we use the if you use the highly
accurate pseudo spectral method, then this
error, this noise free reconstruction,
should going further down here,
so that each electrolys to the ground truth
with the motion accuracy. But instead of,
instead, since we are using low low
water Solver, we have the finite error,
and this finite error may contribute to
this slower decay of the of the error
we observe in numerical experiments. And another
observation is that as we increase the compression
ratio and as we reduce the viscosity, then
now the relative error first decreases,
but each now starting to increase as we as
we increase the super resolution ratio C,
so each because in smaller viscosity, we
have more strict regularity conditions.
And then if we use a higher compression
ratio, and eventually we are going to we
are by we are violating the necessary
conditions for the convergence.
Now we finally get to the
conclusions. So in conclusions,
what you have done is more like a
theoretical analysis of super resolution.
We try to provide some guidelines or theoretical
understanding why the super resolution works,
or if the super resolution of this complex system
actually works so that, and what we found is the
counter intuitively, this theoretical analysis
indicates a decrease of estimation error. That
was very interesting. But one of the so in
this summary, what the most interesting part
is the last item that there is a limitations over
the current study, because the diorica analysis
is mostly limited to isotropic flows, and the
estimate we are getting is very conservative,
meaning that the error bound we provide as a
general convergence actually should be much
larger than what it should be. So we are it's
actually for the follow up study that we are
looking at. Then, how can you expand the
current analysis to more complex flows,
such as some inhomogeneous, turbulent
flows, and how can you get a more sharper
arrow bound than what we currently have so
far? So thank you for your attention, and
thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk. Very fascinating,
awesome. Let's have a Q, a sessions. Okay,
so there are some questions in the chat room
by Sean. I think he already left, but he said,
Thank you for the nice talk. Perhaps a missing
reference from Tama he was sharing, so there's
a link for the paper. Okay, you wanted to share
with you. Okay? The next question is by Kevin.
He's asking, what's an intuitive explanation for
the increasing accuracy with course on Mesh,
while measurement noise is smoothed out by
course of mesh, high frequency flow features
can be preserved by observer flow model?
Yes, that, yeah, that's actually very, very good
question. So that one is that we are smoothing
out by using this filter. Naturally, we are
smoothing out the noise. Then that's good.
But also we are submitting out the small
scale features together with the noise,
so that the question is that there is a balance
that and so that even though we are submitting out
the small high like high wave number features,
by using this observer in Navier solicitation,
we have some kind of, there is energy
cascade is happening. That is the
that is energy is cascading from small,
large scale to small scales. And
when we have sufficient, when this
have,
when, when this energy cascade
happens at a certain scale, less than,
less than certain scales, then
we can actually recover all these
high scale phenomena. That's actually, that's
actually what founding, that's actually what,
what we found in this study, that even though
we have, we don't have information at very,
very small scale. Say that even though we
we filter all the information about 1015,
times Coronavirus scale, we can actually
recover all of these missing information.
We can exactly recover all of these missing
informations by by through the energy cascade,
so that now the what we try to looking at is
actually a balance between these two. One is
that we are having filtering effect. But if
we filter too much, then we cannot recover
the ground truth. So that we are looking at the
we try to get a get a theory that what, how can
you have the balance between these noise filtering
effect as the reconstruction of the ground shoes.
I think your error bounds analysis is kind of
showing that story as well. Yes, exactly. So the
coarse mesh doesn't, shouldn't exceed certain
upper bounds, otherwise you cannot recover
the high frequency. That's why we have
this. Yeah, we have noise. We have
this necessary condition and this new each
viscosity, essentially the right hand side,
define the dissipation rate. So they each
related to the Coronavirus care in turbulence,
so that he should be he the super logical
ratio is a function of some Coronavirus care?
Yeah, probably, but, but we
actually looked at 2d so we
that's also one of the limitations of the current
study. I see, okay, already fascinating for the 2d
next question is by Dave. Thank you for.
A very interesting talk. Your examples were for
2d turbulence, where the energy naturally flows
from small to large scales, inverse cascade.
How would your approach work for 3d turbulence,
when the energy flows from large to small scale?
That's a that's a good Kirsten. That's very good
question. We, frankly speaking, we again, that's
actually why I have the last item in the in the
conclusions, that we certainly admit that there
are limitations of the current story, and because
of the mathematical lack of mathematical tools,
we usually cannot. It's very hard to go to 3d
to do actual proof of convergence in three
turbulence. But what we have seen is that
there is some physical explorations about
what's happening in 3d flows. So in this study,
they actually showed they have some theoretical
derivations of the say critical length scale
to recover the high resolution information.
So we believe that the similar behavior can
be absorbed in 3d but the actual mathematical
proof of convergence is still long way to go.
Okay, all right, next question is by Shima,
thank you so much for such a great talk. I
really enjoyed it. I'm also curious about three
different flow, which is more important, okay,
we are working on it, but
everything takes time understand,
that's awesome. Okay, so I guess I can
ask questions related to the studies,
questions in the beginning,
you know, observing the preserving the those,
conservation of law or some physical property
that's still challenging. Yes, accomplish,
right, right. Okay, so the deep learning models
always the tricky part is that,
how can you make a input, you know, incorporate
hard constraint? It already tricky part so that we
have got many physical solutions, and we want to
reduce the space of solutions that is actually not
mathematically feasible, physically feasible, but
that process is still open. Kirsten, I believe.
Yeah, so still. I mean, the work
you have presented today is very
impressive already. Thank you, yeah.
Thank you. So I keep up the good work. I
I think it's we can wrap up the seminar today.
Let's thank our speaker for the wonderful talk and
through this opportunity, and we can, you
know, you know, establish some collaboration
between Lawrence Livermore and your group,
and sure, we can do greater things together.
But thank you so much for the
wonderful talk. Thank you, yeah,
okay, that concludes. Today's the seminar with.